vous avez la raquette je suis un peu
accablée va dire désolé d'abord d'abord
il y à une contre vérité absolue dans ce
qu'il dit mais absolue c'est que c'est
que la croissance est là la croissance
et à 2 5% en europe en 2010 est plus
élevé que les états unis elle est à 1 8
% en france et devrait être à 2% en 2018
est encore 1,8 en 2020 mais la vérité
c'est qu'on crée des centaines de
milliers d'emplois dans l'hexagone
aujourd'hui même s'il faut en créer
beaucoup pour faire réduire le chômage
la vérité c'est que le chômage baisse
même s'il ne baisse pas assez et pour ça
il faut avoir une politique qui soit une
politique de flexisécurité eyssartier et
la vérité pardonnez moi puisqu'il parle
de l'hôpital c'est que plus on est
endetté
on a d'argent pour l'hôpital et donc en
menant la politique de gribouille
factice hamon alors là on est sûr de son
coup
à l'arrivée on ne meurt pas guéri on
meurt balade c'est à dire que la dette
explose on n'a plus d'argent pour faire
quoi que ce soit en matière de services
publics et en plus on est soumis à la
loi des marchés le plan b à la barre ou
factices n'ai vu en grèce j'ai passé
deux jours en grèce en france on peut
vendre son livre faire des commentaires
faire des listes avec lui la vérité
c'est que les six mois que varoufakis
ont passé au ministère des finances de
la grèce ont ruiné le pays que quand il
a été là à promouvoir son plan b pendant
ce temps là la croissance a été nulle et
que à la fin ils ont fait des dizaines
de milliers de chômeurs en plus en grèce
on lui dit pas merci
et bien en france je souhaite pas
combien de cette politique là c'est une
politique d'hier responsabilités et
d'inefficacité cette année nathis je
t'en prie sortir de deux
la procédure de déficit excessif est
uniquement grâce à la croissance c'est
suffisant c'est satisfaisant emmanuel
macron là vous vous trouvez qu'il en
fait assez justement pour que pour que
ça perdure il va assez loin ou lui dit
quoi fons continue c'est devant ce quels
que soient les ressorts par lesquels on
en sort si c'est suffisant et c'est tant
mieux moi dans ma fonction de
commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques et financières je suis
responsable de la surveillance
budgétaire est ce qui la france deux
années de suite fait moins de 3% et si
en plus les perspectives c'est qu'elle
continue a fait au moins 300 elle
sortira de la pression d'un déficit et
ce sera une bonne nouvelle mais quand on
est sorti la pression des effets
successifs ça ne s'arrête pas il faut
continuer à pédaler il faut réduire les
déficits structurels il faut maîtriser
la dépense publique il faut faire de la
dépense publique intelligente
en effet il faut privilégier l'hôpital
au service de la dette
la meilleure façon d'avoir des hôpitaux
qui marche c'est d'avoir moins de têtes
c'était exactement le contraire que ce
que préconise benoît hamon ce qui
effectivement faudrait quand même bien
de travailler un tout petit peu
l'économie car faire uniquement de la
politique ça mène à une
professionnalisation à compétentes